hello everyone david and karen here from
film courage calm here's our new film
courage format in addition to the audio
that you're here we also now have
visuals so if you're listening to this
podcast on itunes and if you want to
check out the visuals please head over
to our film courage YouTube page and
vice versa if you're watching this video
and you want to sort of download or
listen to the podcast please head over
iTunes today we are so happy to be
speaking with filmmaker Marty lang also
known as Professor Lang that doesn't
like University in Hamden Connecticut
and we had the pleasure of seeing Marty
in action this weekend at the Q media
mashup at Quinnipiac University and it's
very obvious that Marty is well loved
and respected by his students there it's
a very busy guy and we were fortunate to
see him in action hmm in addition to
Marty's teaching and spending time with
his students that you know helping them
on their films he's also the writer
director producer of the his debut
feature film rising star which happens
to star gary plus key emily morris and
michael bara and many more folks are
rising star is going to be having its
world premiere coming up with no
morning's really excited as world
premieres coming up at the seattle true
independent film festival which runs
from may forth to may 12 and he and many
members of his crew all flying out to
seattle he's talking about getting a
penthouse in seattle it sounds like a
lot yeah Wow well please welcome to film
courage Marty Leigh welcome Marty hey
thanks guys glad to be here yeah yeah
we're throwing a hammer um and for those
of you who want to connect with Marty he
is on twitter you can follow him at
Marty underscore lane don't forget the
underscore I'm a more frequent guy that
you know I frequently messed that up
Marty underscore lang and if you want to
learn more about his film rising star
please visit rising star movie com so
morning we see you with a bookshelf in
the background looks like maybe a
backpack on the Shelf there did you just
finish teaching your students I did
actually just finished our class about
half an hour ago on Tuesday nights I
teach a writing and producing media
class for upperclassmen so we had a day
full of one
rough cuts of five minutes silent
narrative film so it was a movie full
day today oh very cool all right nice
well we want to thank you for having us
at the Q mashup we just flew back in
last night and I have to say it's such a
beautiful campus we were telling a few
people while we were still in
Connecticut about it and I mean it looks
like a ski lodge it's beautiful student
center it overlooks like what is it all
of hamden I mean it's gorgeous RR York
Hill campus is where the qu mashup took
place and its really up on on the top
hill where you can see all of him then
all day Haven clear day you can see all
the way to fly out and sound yeah it's
gorgeous out there it's really great
look great place to have an event very
cool yeah we were very fortunate to
attend so thank you so much for having
us really good time it was a much needed
break for us here too so we we
appreciate you getting us out of our
sort of comfort zone a little bit yeah
flying out there yeah one of the
favorite part is that we're going to
remember is after the Q mashup you know
we had our private screening of rising
star they get you set up for us on
campus and that was really cool said
them just just you and I our own little
private theater watching white as a star
and then from there with Lucas McNally
be headed down to New Haven had pizza
there and then and then we and we sort
of strolled over to the park there right
outside right outside the Yale campus
and then we got some some exclusive sort
of part interview video footage karen
has some really cool cool photos that
she took so we're looking forward to
sharing that sort of additional bonus
footage you know in the upcoming weeks
ya know for the next few day is actually
on some are you with your students when
you're in front of them do you give them
any tough love real world advice or do
you just stick to the curriculum I try
to do a little bit of both the great
thing about going to be act is that
there's a great curriculum set up now
for the students to go through and learn
about all the the technical pieces of
production but there are times where you
know you need to kind of put your foot
down and kind of tell them more stories
and things like that because this is a
tough business and you know we're not
doing our job if we're not really
prepared
them for when they get out of school and
when they answer this world you know so
whether it's teaching them how to run a
crowdfunding campaign let you guys did
with us at the mash-up or if it's you
know sitting in class and and really
hammering home you know a film that a
student may think is perfect but really
has some issues you know we're not we're
doing them a disservice if we're not
completely honest with them about what
they need to do get stuff better so
honesty tends to be one of my stronger
points in that regard can you give us
some examples of a couple Marty isms um
Oh God well the first one is your script
will never turn into your film that's
the first thing I always tell them um no
matter how you know easy you may have
something in your head you know how how
specific you have a film in your head
there's always going to be things that
pop up that you're not expecting and I
give them examples of that from you know
from my own work when we did when we
shot rising star I actually had a part
written for myself that I had to cut
because we didn't have enough time to
shoot it so that was a little bit of
bruising a ego but you know it's it's
what you need to tell these kids you
know it's filmmaking stuff you know so
if things don't go your way you have to
learn to be adaptable and that's really
something that I try to teach them you
know in all my classes you know just to
try to kind of roll roll the punches as
much as possible knowing that the end
goal is to create a film that somebody
can watch that's the ultimate thing you
know we do have good news for those
tuning in wondering like wait a minute
you know Marty said he just cut himself
on his own film are we still going to
see Marty in the film and you know as
witnesses to the film you know we've
seen it and we've seen the little sort
of sneak cameo you know Marty does find
a way to get inside you know Karen so to
bed sweet she's like there's Marty
there's parties so you gotta look out
for that in rising star you know I want
to take it back Marty because this is
this is what's really wild to me you and
I went to to high school together the
same high school in Connecticut we
played basketball together you know so
this goes back many years and it's wild
how sort of our lives went often two
different paths and then sort of found
them to find their way back together
once again
here but back then did you know did you
have any idea that sort of filmmaking
was in your future back when I knew you
from newington high school um I didn't
think that filmmaking would be in my
future but I knew that storytelling
would be I when when I was 13 14 years
old the warm bowl that I had in my life
was to become a journalist I always
wanted to write for newspapers I wanted
to write for magazines and that was sort
of my one goal going through high school
in college and it was funny I didn't
really the only film exposure I ever had
through undergraduate was when i worked
at blockbuster when i went say yukon and
then i took one screenwriting class my
last semester as an undergrad and that
sort of propelled me you know into that
world a little bit more so when i was a
kid i mean i was always telling stories
i was always writing stuff and it was
funny when i was 13 i remember writing
in my middle school yearbook that my one
goal was to be a reporter for The New
York Times and I worked out when I was
22 actually did it so I was kind of cool
did you have an artistic family growing
up um I i think my the big thing that we
had in our family was music I know my
dad was a huge fan of Andre review the
the orchestra director so I mean they're
always be music playing in the house you
know while we were growing up and I
wasn't so much a an orchestral fan I was
more of a hip-hop fan when I was growing
up so I listened to a lot of that kind
of stuff but I think I think music was
probably the biggest piece of the arts
that we had growing up um you know I'd
go see movies you know just like
everybody else would but for us it was
more about animal house and ghostbusters
than it was you know something like the
Godfather so were you encouraged to be
creative yeah don't definitely both my
parents were very supportive than that
and still are you know my mom is one of
my biggest fans not which is great I was
a huge help to us while we're making the
phone yeah that was there was one thing
that was really cool about growing up my
sister was actually an outstanding
actress she got involved in a lot of
drama and like musicals in high school
and stuff like that I never did any of
that because I was playing basketball a
lot and that kept me out of the time
to actually play in the place as you
remember Dave but I played saxophone in
the band and you know went to Disney
World and performed at Epcot Center and
stuff like that so there was definitely
a big beautiful you know benta to me
when I was growing up you said you know
you really for you know filmmaking
really didn't sort of come on the scene
for you until really you know I have the
tail end of your college career you know
after your college career you know which
is somewhat unusual you know you often
find that filmmakers for them the
journey begins you know maybe in their
early teenage years you can do you
remember what your first filmmaking
experience was I do actually uh yeah and
it was pretty bad now that i think about
um my uh my best friend Damien we had
made a film with his brother and his
sister and the family dog and a huge
plush bunny we did this stupid heist
film called the quest for the Queen's
jewels and it was like maybe three
minutes long it was all one take it was
all in camera I must have been oh god I
must have been late we 16 or 17 years
old and it was fun and it was cool you
know it was something good to do for the
day but I never really thought that it
was something that would become kind of
a career for me it wasn't until you know
a lot later on you know after I got out
of undergrad that I started thinking
about it more seriously and then so what
was it exactly when you started to get
into a little bit more you know can you
talk about when you when you first
started believing in yourself as a
filmmaker because that's the crucial
part is you know you have to get to a
point where it's like you know what
there's something I'm doing here where I
need to keep doing this right well there
were actually there were two big moments
um the first one was obviously the first
film that I ever worked on I found out
that I went for some reason I thought
that all the films that were being made
in the world you know you can find them
in one place I went on up on an episode
of The Hollywood Reporter and I looked
through it for all the films that were
in production and there was only one in
Connecticut at the time and it was a
film call the little bit of lipstick
started me and Tyler Liv Tyler's
half-sister on soupy sales if you
remember him
um so I went to go work on that phone as
a PA and I stayed on that film for
better part of three years and just kept
showing up kept showing up I was a boom
operator when we were in production I
was the post supervisor and then by the
time the film was done I was the only
person that was still working with the
director so he gave me a producer credit
so that turned out to be amazing so that
really get kind of gave me the
confidence that I could do it or I could
learn to do it because I had gone
through the process once and kind of
knew what it was but as far as thinking
about it as a career I still hadn't
really confirmed on that until I had an
interview actually when I was writing
for The New York Times I had a chance to
sit down and have lunch with amy
brenneman not if you remember her she
was on judging amy she was in heat she
actually was getting an award at a
connecticut college and they sent me out
to interviewer and kind of find out you
know what the whole story was because
she grew up in Connecticut she's from
Glastonbury and her mom you know was a
longtime resident you know a judge here
and she really talked to me about what
the business was like and what a life
was working in film and it really kind
of sounded exciting to me and I never
really thought about it in those terms
you know I always thought about it was
something fun to do maybe you know
something to do in your spare time so
after I did that interview it kind of
hit me you know maybe this is something
that I could do for a career and that's
where it started to build from there so
that that really was kind of a turning
point for me tell us where you were in
your life when you wrote the script for
rising star um not the best place I I
had a job I was working for a company
that did that built boilers it was an
engineering company and they had just
started up a video division and I came
in there to help them with making
training videos and stuff like that you
know not not exactly gone with the wind
um and one of the things that we used to
do was they would have us travel you
know we'd go down to other plants and in
Tennessee and in other countries went to
the Czech Republic we have to go to
Paris we got to go to Germany and while
we were on those flights while we were
traveling I would just sort of jot down
ideas because that job really took up a
lot of my life
and I really wanted to keep it as long
as I could because honestly paid pretty
good so I wanted to you know try to stay
there as long as I could and I started
realizing that other pieces of my life
were suffering as a result of it so I
just started you know it's kind of a
conversation in my head like do I really
want to live to work or do I just want
to work to live so that's kind of a
rising star began you know and you know
at this stage you know because I mean
how recently was how recent was this
Marty when you're working on the script
I started working on the script in 2009
I started working on it okay so okay so
you so you're already sort of in that
process of maybes riding and developing
and having short films underneath your
belt you know because I just think I
mean can you talk a little bit more
about you know where you were in terms
of your career you know in terms of
starting and stopping many projects I
mean how how vital was it for you to
sort of maybe write this script and then
sedol way through and I know for me you
know before I was able to finally get to
a point where I'm working on my debut
feature phone there are a lot of
projects that I sort of started and
stopped beforehand yet that it was it
was really important that this be the
first one I think because I had a couple
projects to that I had started writing I
had gotten halfway through writing and I
never really found the you know the time
or the energy to really push through and
finish anything and part of that was
because of work because I was working so
much um so you know rising star was
really important because it really was
the first project that I saw through
script wise to a point where I thought
wow I could actually do this I could
actually make this and it was another
kind of transition for me too because
that would have been and ultimately
became the first project that I directed
in addition to producing up until that
point I had produced i think it was six
feature films you know I associate
producer co-producer producer you know
working in that job and you know they
had all been seen through and they were
all created and they were all finished
and men
I think four of them ended up getting
distributed so I had a pretty good track
record as a producer but I hadn't taken
that next step and really created a
project from nothing that I would
oversee and this really would be end up
being that project so it really was
important you know that I that I get
this thing done how long did you work on
the script for a little over a year um
you know in fits and starts you know I'd
work on it a little bit when you know as
in the Prague Airport or you know when I
was at the bus station and in Tennessee
and all that kind of thing so it kind of
went in in pieces the other cool thing
too about about writing this script was
I wanted to figure out a way to include
a lot of landmarks with in Hartford that
are culturally relevant to the outside
world so part of the script wasn't so
much writing as it was just driving
around town and seeing what was there
and what I could incorporate into the
story because I wanted to try to find
ways to make the you know the story
takes place in Hartford Connecticut the
capital of the state but I wanted it to
be something that would become much
bigger and that a lot more people would
be able to identify with because of
people like Mark Twain you know like the
you know people of that caliber you know
would make the story a little bit bigger
so I wanted to try to find ways to do
that incorporate those so that was as
much a part of a writing process as the
actual writing laws and at what point
did you I mean did you know for certain
like this is going to be a film i'm
going to make like this is going to be
the first feature film it was it at the
tail end of the writing process or did
you know fairly early on I had a feeling
that it was that it would be the one
pretty early on but the only question
was when it would happen because the
whole time that I was writing it I was
still working this job and you know I
was still trying to hold on to that and
you know work as far as I could there so
to be able to ask for the time off to
make that film wouldn't exactly put me
at the top of the list for you know for
employees so I wanted to try to keep it
in my back pocket as long as I could but
then fortunately as it turned out our
whole department got laid off
and that was in the springtime of 2010
so once we got laid off and I was
blessed with an unemployment check I I
started thinking you know well if we can
do it we can do it now so that's when I
started rounding up everybody and you
know talking to Gary and talking to
Emily and Michael and trying to make
sure that they were available and you
know casting all the other parts and you
know started really put it together you
know we can tell from seeing the film
you know and you've mentioned sort of
going after certain locations and trying
to incorporate that into things you know
you you know you try to write in respect
to what you had access to or may have
access to you know meaning that you kept
the production you know what would be
the production budget down but as you
said you know we're going to go out and
try to make this film did you seek
traditional financing like I mean did
you put in an effort to say okay we're
going to try to get some investors
behind it so we can actually make it
make the movie or was it something kind
of like you knew all along like when I
go to make this I'm going to have to
sort of maybe put my own money into it
this to see this through well I kind of
knew I'd have to put some of my own
money into it to get it made only
because I wasn't willing to wait that
long we we had tried to apply for for
funds through the City of Hartford they
actually have a really great grant
program for people in the arts and we
had applied for what ultimately would
have been about two-thirds of the
production budget through the city and I
foolishly went on the assumption that we
were going to get that as we kept going
through pre-production and as it turned
out we didn't get it so we had to kind
of change gears then we had two other
investors that put in a small amount of
money but when it came down to it you
know we had the Kickstarter campaign
which we were you know which we were
talking about running from the beginning
anyway but that became sort of the money
that would get us through production and
then it then ultimately ended up you
know costing us a little bit more that i
ended up paying for to get us through
production and then we sort of regrouped
after we shot it but i kind of knew from
the beginning you know I we wanted to
try to find bigger investors and we had
a couple meetings and people were
interested but no one really committed
by the check so we we kind of hit the
point where we said you know what we're
just going to go ahead and do this
ourselves because it's really
way it's going to happen and i love the
lead character in the film Eliza what
can you tell us about her oh well Eliza
is played by Emily Morse and eliza's
character who is sort of the opposite of
Chris a lead character in the film she's
kind of a bohemian kind of a free spirit
you know really doesn't live by any
structure in life she has a lot of
different interests artistically but she
really doesn't have one major avenue
that she's committed to yet so it's kind
of interesting because she plays well
off of Chris who has his one avenue that
he devotes everything to any Enzo you
know in a in a rough situation as a
result of that we find out over through
the course of the film that Eliza's
having a little bit of trouble spreading
herself as thin as she done this so
having these two characters kind of play
off each other is nice because they
represent both extremes of the i guess
the work-life continuum and and is that
what drew you to this dynamic you like
those extremes or what was it about
those two characters why did you put
them together well I mean honestly both
of those characters are different facets
of my own personality I mean there are
times where i get so maniacally devoted
to something that i put the blinders on
and i can't see anything else and there
are other times where I'm spread so thin
I'm doing a million different things and
I can't give the energy that each thing
deserves so I thought it was important
to show both of those extremes because
honestly neither one is healthy you know
I in it what I hope the film sort of
communicates is that finding that
balance really is the key to to finding
a fulfilling life hmm so was it
questioning that 40-hour workweek sort
of world that drew you to this film
because you were living it at that time
or probably more than 40 hours with all
the travel and everything was that word
yeah yeah I mean it's I thought that was
something that needed to be explored
because so many other people are dealing
with that now you know I mean when we
made it you know it was a little closer
to the you know the two
Nate economic crisis but even now you
know it's it's much the same you know
people are worried about the jobs that
they have how long they're going to have
them um you know every day become sort
of a you know a stressful day because is
today the day that I get laid off starts
creeping in your head and you start
thinking about that every single day and
I knew that because that's what I was
dealing with when I was at that job you
know so and I'm single I don't have kids
I don't have a family so I can only
imagine how much more stressful it is if
you have people that depend on you and
you're dealing with something like that
so that really you know the more I
thought about that the more the more I
kind of realized this is something that
can't connect with a lot of people
absolutely and morning you mentioned
that the state of Connecticut was so
accommodating in helping you to secure
the locations of rising star what's
involved in shooting around the hartford
area and other towns in connecticut
honestly not that much it was it was a
really smooth process for us we we
approached the City of Hartford we
approached the mayor's office and at the
time a woman who was the communications
director you know really took to us
really like the project she Ford us
there's no real set in stone film
apparatus within the city but there's a
permitting office that's there you know
for any time you want to have an event
at a public space so we talked with the
permitting director and he literally
like gave us you know carte blanche
whatever we wanted as long as we just
you know had all the information given
to them given to the police things like
that you know it really worked out very
smoothly any any City Street we had
access to it anytime didn't have to pay
for it didn't have to pay for police you
know it was really smooth and as far as
like some of the the other places in
town the private places it's just like
anything else you go when you talk with
you enter in replace and try to know try
to get permission that way but even in
that case that worked out smoothly too
because we had we made a little press
before we went into production so a lot
of people knew about us as we were
coming around so honestly the the
process was pretty smooth I mean were
you scared at all in terms of what you
have written into the script and then
you know I mean actually approaching the
Mark Twain House and smelly
Sully's the the you know the bar there
they're like sort of the night club rat
bhar you have another you have another
club that you sort of use another bar
location I mean where you sort of scared
of like wait a minute we might not be
able to get these locations especially
at our production budget level I was
horrified um and I honestly thought that
something would fall apart at some point
but nothing ever did we shot this we
shot the film the way I wrote it in the
places that we wrote it for and
amazingly everyone kind of helped out
and you know did what they could to
accommodate us like a two great stories
with Sully's as we were you know getting
ready for pre-production I hadn't been
in the bar when I was writing the script
I knew of the bar because Emily who
played Eliza the first time she ever did
an open mic was at that bar so I kind of
wrote it just assuming you know that
we'd be able to go down there and get it
you know I never went down there before
we got into pre-production but as soon
as we did and the word started getting
out about the film I got an email on
facebook from the owner of Sully's
saying if you what if you need to use my
bar restaurant come down and you can use
whatever you want so I don't know if he
found out about us ahead of time you
know he's friends with Emily so maybe
they talked ahead of time I don't know
but um that was really nice i went down
and i talked with them and I mean he
hoped me when I walked in the bar so
that turned out very nice not only that
because you told us this story when we
just saw you and you actually brought
him the script and you're like I want
you to read this script I mean that's
just such a just such a serendipitous
moment and it's unbelievable it was
great it was really cool and it made me
feel really good you know that we'd have
the goodwill that we'd need to get
through this whole process you know it
was really nice and then like with the
Mark Twain House you know I didn't think
no feature film had ever shot in the
Mark Twain House before us were the very
first one so when we went down there and
you know I expected some sort of
resistance or maybe you know a play for
money and there was you know and then
and we told them you know look you know
we're not shooting with you know with
any money at all but you know can we can
we make this work
and what we suggested was look you know
the 20 house has been having financial
problems as many nonprofits have in the
last few years so we said look you know
if you let a shoot in this house for a
much reduced rate normally they charge
about four hundred dollars an hour we
got in there for about 50 so they said
that if you know if we can go in there
and shoot you know for the five hours
that we need it in exchange for that
reduced rate when we get a rough cut of
the film will play it at the Mark Twain
museum and you can keep all the ticket
proceeds so what ended up happening was
when we screen there we sold out so what
they would have made two thousand
dollars you know have they charged
normal rate they made almost twice that
because of the tickets that they got
from us so it really it worked out for
everybody involved it was a really good
deal yeah I love hearing that especially
hearing sort of the hustle that you put
in behind the scenes may that's us great
to hear and and on and also just all
this about about the sort of local
community getting behind your production
efforts you know that that's what we
love about regional filmmaking because
you can have that best support of sort
of your local community you know they
love getting behind these projects and
and when you watch rising star you see
the production value it's just through
the roof you know like you're you're
taking this this modest Kickstarter
budget you know you guys raised 16,000
or twenty thousand dollars on
Kickstarter 15,000 be raised at 15,000
on Kickstarter I know you've had some
months of small investors putting some
their own money you put it a little bit
more real money just to raise the budget
slightly but you're easily seeing like
this six-figure you know production
value budget you know when you actually
see it all translated on a film and it's
just really great to see you know can
you talk a little bit about I mean were
there any challenges securing location
any locations throughout the film and
also what was the grand total it you
guys spent for your locations well I can
tell you our grand total for locations
was about I think it was five hundred
dollars because we spent about I think
it was about three at the Mark Twain
House and the rest of the money we spent
getting access to a hartford city bus
that we were able to use driving around
my sis that's all we spent oh yeah it
was it's nice yeah worth it I that's an
advantage you know for anyone outside of
Los Angeles outside and you work outside
of the major cities you know that's an
advantage you guys have with the region
of filmmaking you know that you just see
that that people do want to support the
local filmmaker yeah it's it's a big
thing I mean you know when you're
shooting a film in Hartford you're not
one of a number of films that are
shooting there you're you're the only of
the first film that's been there in six
months in a year you know in five years
you know that kind of thing so people
really are excited you know when you get
a film coming in town so and as a
regional filmmaker I think that's one of
the biggest things that draws me to it
you know is the idea that you can go
into an area where there's not normally
a lot of production so the people that
are there and I hate to use this word
you know they're not jaded of the
production that's there and they're not
you know looking you know to serve their
own financial interest first um you know
they're they're willing to work with you
and in a lot of cases you know you get
access to things that you might not get
access to you can find resources that
you might not usually get you know get
resources from you know we found a
number of our locations number of the
houses that you see in the film we found
by Facebook we actually set up google
doc you know if anyone has any help that
they'd like to offer us Gary Pulaski was
great setting this up with us you know
there were people that were offering us
things left and right like we had an
offer a gentleman a farmer had access to
a herd of goats and said that if we
wanted to we could use his goats in our
film that made me want to write a scene
with goats in it because I never thought
I'd have access to anything like that so
you know that kind of thing is really
cool you never know where you're going
to find help from and we found locations
that way people actually left notes on
you know on the google doc that they
were willing to let us shoot in their
home I mean as a filmmaker you pray for
that stuff so it really really worked
out well Wow let me be careful Marty
because you know you're giving caring
all these ideas nice thing you know
she's gonna set this all up and make a
film or grown in Connecticut when you
were in
what by The Hartford Courant and then
also Channel 3 News something like that
it looks like you you had suppressed
there I'm curious too about the economic
development plan that you implemented
with rising starter you touched on that
on the movie site can you tell us more
about it yeah I mean one of the things
that I was trying to do with the making
of this film was to prove to the state
and to people living here that the film
industry can be something that can
create business for a lot of people um
you know we tried to partner with local
businesses that were you know that we're
giving discounts for customers that they
mentioned the movie you know part of the
press that we did I actually got in
touch with the Hartford business journal
and they did an article you know about
us and how we were trying to use as much
local vendors as possible you know our
entire crews from Connecticut about the
vast majority ninety-eight percent of
our crews from Connecticut we have a
workforce development program in the
state for the film industry it's called
the Connecticut film industry training
program and we were able to pull a
number of the brightest graduates out of
that program to come and work on this
film and a number of them have since
going on to earn their union cards now
they're working on bigger films now so
you know I wanted to really use this
film as an example to the state that you
know that the film industry isn't all
100 million dollar films you know there
are there are homegrown companies that
are trying to sprout up here to make
these films and it really I think it did
you know catch a lot of people by by
surprise as we were going through it you
know I do radio spots you know for like
business oriented shows and things like
that and it was a different way for
people to think about a film being made
an indie film being made rather you know
you think of a hundred million dollars
from coming into the state they're going
to spend a ton of money there's going to
be a lot of economic return from that
but the smaller films can do that too
and that really helped to kind of
educate people hear about how that can
happen Omarion listening to you and and
you know very bright guy you know very
very personable you know i'm just like
listening to the efforts you're putting
in behind the scene
means with what you're doing in
Connecticut I mean I mean does this sort
of effort I mean would that translate to
other people in Connecticut or other
people in smaller towns throughout the
country and did you think they'd be able
to take some of the stuff that you're
doing and doing it wherever they are and
then they're only I sure hope so I mean
there's I mean obviously every area is
going to be different as far as what the
political climate is you know but there
are certain things that are consistent
no matter where you are and that is you
know if you make a film in a town you're
going to spend money in that time you
know and if you want to help with
developing a workforce in a particular
area shooting a film in that area will
provide opportunities for those people
to work I so I think you know I've been
lucky in Connecticut because we we've
been very we've been very progressive as
far as finding opportunities to develop
this industry here and I'm forever
grateful for that governor realm you
know she started the tax credit program
in 2006 and Governor Malloy has
continued it when since he's come into
office year ago so you know we've been
lucky here than that we have a tax
credit program here we have a workforce
development program not many states have
that um you know but it's also taking
advantage of what you do have that's a
big part of it too so I mean if you're
living in you know Kenosha Wisconsin and
you want to try to get a film like this
off the ground you can do a lot of the
things that we did to try to make a film
like this but I think it's important it
when you're looking at it this way you
really have to start when you write the
script thinking about these things
because if you're looking to incorporate
you know items of local interest state
interest national interest you need to
find them and then you need to find a
way to build a story around them so it
really comes back to what you're writing
and and how you plan for that and we
really did that from the beginning like
we were talking the the whole idea for
this film started when when Gary Pulaski
and I went to go see a phone call
medicine for melancholy that played in
New York and my friend Barry I went to
film school with him he directed it and
the film just blew me away it was pure
vote was amazing but it really had a
political bent to it in that you know
the city of San Francisco was a major
character in that film so we started
talking that night you know is there a
way that we can make a film about
Hartford that's sort of the same idea
that kind of makes the city a character
there and that's what got us talking
about okay well we need to include Mark
Twain somehow you know it would it would
need to include Wallace Stevens somehow
you know those those are sort of the
basic ideas and then as things started
to take shape you know you can build
from that but it's really got to be
something that you think about from the
beginning of your production you know
and then what about the next step you
know once you have it built into your
script you know who do you begin to
reach out to first and then how do you
go about doing so well I mean obviously
it's a case by case thing um you know
for us I thought it made the most sense
to approach the city first because if
you can get the city behind the project
they have inroads to whatever cultural
landmarks are within its borders so if
the city is on board and they enjoy the
project and they think it's going to be
strong they can refer you to someone who
works at the Mark Twain House they can
call you know the the cemetery owner
where Wallace Stevens grave site is and
they can lay the foundation for you so
that when you show up you're not just
chill filmmaker you're the guy that the
city called about and I think that makes
a big difference you know if you don't
have a press out already about what the
project is to have someone in your
corner from the very beginning I think
that's a really strong way to go about
you know trying to get a phone like this
going yeah that's great advice thank you
for sharing Marty you know in terms of
coming back in terms of getting this
this this film off the ground you know
you did you did decide that you know I
hate you know what we're gonna go with
Kickstarter for this can you talk a
little bit about that decision to turn a
crowdfunding to turn the Kickstarter for
the production budget yeah I mean you
know I gotta be honest and it's funny
that I'm talking to you guys about it
goodbye promise was a big reason why we
decided to do a Kickstarter campaign we
saw we saw you know what you guys had
done and and I do nothing about it at
that point at all so and I was scared to
death of it you know but we the more we
looked at
and you know the more Gary that I had
done a lot of research about it too
before we got going and you know it
looked like it was something that was
doable for us you know and the thing
that's a little bit different in our
approach for the Kickstarter campaign
versus the majority of them was that we
thought we'd be able to get the majority
of the money from people locally so we
weren't thinking so much looking
nationwide and international you know
for the crowd we thought okay well
there's 400 graduates of the Connecticut
industry training program maybe we can
get five bucks from all of them so you
know we have the email list and we knew
those people and we do a lot of people
that were local you know all the above
the line filmmakers have their own
networks you know that we were able to
utilize but it ended up we got
eighty-six percent of our donations from
people that we knew so that was sort of
a flip you know from what most
successful campaigns are doing now but
we knew that we'd be able to get a
strong amount of money in small amounts
from those people so when not when we
started it that was kind of how we
focused it and it took you know we we
kind of had you know like all the other
campaigns we have the big start and then
we have the wall all the way through you
know we had a 45-day campaign and there
were about 30 of them or nothing
happened which freaked me out and then
you know as we started getting towards
the end like all the other campaigns you
know we started getting a little bit of
a rise and you know we got a huge
donation from a friend of mine and went
to high school won powerball and that
helped us huge yeah that's always helps
um so yeah we ended up getting our goal
so it was it was a different kind of
structure you know that most campaigns
would do but ultimately it was
successful and how big was your
crowdfunding team was it just you and
Gary there were basically three of us
that were at the helm Gary and I and
then our producer match of energy we
were sort of like the keys to the
campaign and you know three of us we
kind of took home yeah we met Matt this
weekend yeah it was fun meeting Matt you
know and you know something we haven't
necessarily brought up a lot of here on
film pers is I mean did you believe I
mean you know we have Karl funny but do
you believe that the filmmakers should
use crowdfunding more than once you know
just keep going back
keep crowdfunding over and over again um
well it depends it depends on a lot of
things um you know one is excuse me one
is the size of the project what another
one is the time in between projects if
you try to do something every six months
and you're going to the wealth of the
same people I think it's a legitimate
concern that those people might get
tapped out um you know and you also have
to worry about following through on what
you promised you know if you raise a
certain amount of money for a film in
that film doesn't get made your
credibility takes a big hit and in in
the crowdfunding world your reputation
is gold and that's that's what people go
to you know so I mean we we made it a
point and I mean even now you know two
plus years I think after completing our
campaign we're still getting perks back
to people we're still making videos that
we promised people and it may take us
through summer to get all that stuff
done so you know you got to make sure
before my own view is that if you're
going to do crowdfunding multiple times
you want to make sure that whatever
you're working on now is completely paid
back completely finished the project is
done it's out to who it needs to go to
and all of that has been taken care of
in my view only at that point can you go
back to the well and say okay now i'm
working on this and in that case I think
it's a good thing because now you have a
successful campaign behind you or more
you know depending on what point you're
in that's the biggest deal you know it's
it's all about what your reputation is
and if people can trust you to get done
what you say you're going to get done I
think that's the biggest thing you know
and I've mentioned you mentioned earlier
that you know you know you would love to
teach a course you know at quinnipiac
that sort of revolves around
crowdfunding and then we met one of your
students there at quinnipiac who is
currently crowdfunding for his his film
right now as doctors wrestling
documentary about a fellow student
whether that's the wrestling I'm a
bodybuilding I'm sorry bodybuilding
documentary forgive me you know what
happens when you do have a student
or maybe there's a fellow filmmaker hear
that that's watching or listening what
advice would you give to them in terms
of like that goes for the teetering of
like should I crowdfunding should or not
what would you tell them Oh crowd fun
definitely um but take the time to learn
how it works first I think you know one
of the things that you would actually
send a you know at the mashup makes a
lot of sense for you to go and actually
follow someone else's campaign and get
the word out about them to see what your
own Reach is I think that's a huge thing
and I think I wish we had done that
before we had started up with ours
because it would have helped me
understand a little bit more the idea of
you know the notes you know the the
people who can then get the word out for
you to their networks that didn't
totally make sense to me until we were
in the middle of the campaign and had I
known that before I probably would have
taken the time to you know to really
figure that out and see how big my own
influence was you know within the social
media world um yeah I mean if you take
the time to really follow a couple
campaigns that are similar to yours you
know figure out you know what perks are
what levels you put them at exactly what
you'll be giving out you know I think I
think anybody can do it and I think
anybody can be successful I mean I Corey
the student of mine that you guys had
meant that you guys worked with he's
aunt unbelievably right now I saw him
today he's like I can't believe like how
much I learned it was the greatest thing
ever and now he's putting in that work
he's going to be successful he's going
to meet his goal and then what that's
going to do is that's going to get him
even more jazz for when he graduates and
we wants to do his own project he'll
have the confidence to put something
together where you can make a bigger
amount of money and I love the idea of
crowdfunding while you're in college and
as you have access to so many people all
around you every day I mean who are all
on social media yeah they're all us you
know that it's a very enviable position
to be in you know you know swing it over
to the distribution side of things
because not now the film is complete I
mean you know you've worked Oh quite a
while you know the getting this film
done it's done in terms of your mindset
your strategy for district
you know we know it's going to be
premiering at the Seattle to independent
film festival did you always have film
festivals in mind you know from day one
of like this is where we're going with
his film once it's completed I did in
the local sense the local regional sense
the the plan that we had and I actually
we have an Excel spreadsheet that lists
all the festivals that were that were
targeting we wanted to make sure that
this film made a huge splash in New
England that was the goal for us because
it's a film about Connecticut you know
it's kind of a romantic film you know
it's really I think audiences will
respond positively to it what we wanted
to do was really get the New England
film community excited about us and to
that end what we ended up doing the
Connecticut Film Festival which is the
big festival here at home I've worked
for them for about five years on their
educational director and what I did was
I brought them on board instead of the
other way around I told the director Tom
I said look you know I want to debut
this film that I wanted to make a big
splash I want your press resources for
it and I want you to share in the
success of it because I think it's
really going to make a big you know
splash in the state so what we did we
decided that we were going to do two
things we're going to have an opening
weekend of playing the filming
Connecticut two nights once privately at
a private location which we're still
trying to lock down but then another
public location where people can come
and see it for free the idea being the
more people that can come and see it and
the more positive buzz that we can get
out of it the better it'll help
everybody and then what we were going to
do after that was we were going to give
the film to the Connecticut film
festival so that they can play it at all
their different spots Connecticut's an
interesting film festival that they
don't have a once annual fest they play
all year long and they play all over the
state in different theatres so what
we're doing is we're giving them the
film and saying take it with you on your
tour over the course of this year so
that when it plays theatrically it'll
play in new haven connecticut one
weekend it'll play in stamford
connecticut the next weekend you know in
different parts of the state so that
more people can get an idea of what the
film is and what we think that's going
to do is
increase our visibility for when we go
for online DVD or VOD deals that we may
do down the line we're keeping the focus
for this film regional because we think
we can gather more interest that way and
then whatever we get outside of that is
bonus obviously we're in we're hoping
that we can get a lot of that the
Seattle festival will definitely be a
part of that um but really we're
concentrating on making sure that the
New England states know about us you
know screen us and people get excited
about us I mean you know can-can you
know speaking of regionally can you talk
about you know how how are you going to
go about doing that like what are you
going to put into I mean who are you
reaching out to who you getting involved
till you spread the word to within sort
of New England that northeast part of
the country you know to build that buzz
what exactly are you doing well there's
two things um we've got the the New
England film festivals are the ones that
we're approaching now so like Rhode
Island international New Hampshire Maine
international Woods Hole Massachusetts
those types of festivals are the ones
that were applying to and there's
already advanced buzz about us at a lot
of them so that's definitely good and
then once once the Connecticut festival
you know what's the Connecticut premier
happens we'll reach out again to them
you know to try to get more word out
about it and the other thing that we're
trying to do and this is sort of kind of
like a work in progress we're trying to
find independent theaters within those
states that we can go to to have our own
theatrical events at and that would be
separate of the festivals but it would
be kind of an extension of the
theatrical run that would come I'm
hoping after the first two or three
festivals that we play at so then when
we start going to these places where we
control the ticket sales and we have
obviously you know can get a lot more
profit wise you know they'll be worried
about the film already and people will
be interested to come and see it because
of a hopeful successful festival
screening you know in a particular state
so that's kind of where we're going with
it did you receive any personal contact
from other large festivals and if so who
reached out to you and what did they say
well we we had
contact from a couple big festivals we
we won the Indy wire project of the
month last September and as a result of
that we were able to get a consultation
with the Sundance Institute and it
worked out nicely because since it was
September it was right around the
deadline for features to be sent to them
so they had asked us to see the film and
it wasn't done at that point so we sent
them a rough cut of it they watched it
and we had a consultation with a woman
named Kim yutani who's one of the
coolest people I've ever talked to you
know really kind of like broke down the
process of how Sundance picked their
films and told us you know you have a
strong film and it's going to play well
the festival's it ultimately didn't get
in so we didn't we didn't get that joke
unfortunately on we also after we had
won the Indy wire contest we got a call
from Tribeca and they were interested in
seeing us as well as a result of winning
that so we sent them a copy and then
when they were about ready to select
their films they had contacted us and
asked us to send the newer version of it
because they were still interested in us
of aptly so we sent that new version to
them the almost final cut probably like
a month before we we picture media we
finished the phone and we got a letter
from them you know the film was in the
conversation getting in but ultimately
there wasn't room for it so we didn't
get into that one either um but the cool
news is Seattle true independent where
the film is going to world premiere
that's the first festival that's seen
the finished version of the swamp far as
I'm concerned we're one for one so
that's pretty cool okay morning you're
active on Twitter very popular what made
you join it some people are still not
not sure about Twitter what made you
join it gary plus key maybe joint
working uh yeah it took my pirate
posture so it took him about two years
to do it I was originally really
skeptical I didn't know what it was
about I didn't know how it could help I
didn't know anything but I started he
find them nor me down I got an account
and the more I got into it you know the
the nicer it was the easier it became
having worked as a journalist
microblogging actually makes a lot of
sense to me because it's kind
like writing headlines so that really
kind of it came to me pretty easy and
it's my favorite social networking site
now why were you skeptical of it because
I didn't know it honestly I mean
facebook makes sense in that you know
you have a photo element you have a
video element you have a posting element
stuff like that but on Twitter it's 140
characters and there's these weird
things called hashtags and and I don't
understand how this works so it took a
little while to kind of get the hang of
it but you know like anything you know
you get through the curve and then you
become a good user what do you tell your
students about Twitter if you do I tell
them you need to be on Twitter and you
need to be on Twitter for more than
telling people where you're drinking
tonight um I I try to get through to
them that any kind of social networking
is good but especially for the indie
phone community there's a there is a
community there and they're very helpful
and they're very supportive so you know
if you're serious about getting into
this you need to have all the resources
at your disposal that you can have so
you know why not be a part of that
community and help them out have them
help you and you tell them any sort of
um social faux paws they should avoid
for twitter and also things that they
should be doing um I mean really I
subscribe to Sheree cameras roll you
know for every ten suites you have nine
should be about something else other
than yourself you know promoting other
people's work or you know / you know
promoting discussion or anything like
that that's really the big thing you
know to try to make it more about
getting the word out about stuff that
you find interesting and information
that you think can help people um you
know that's that's really the biggest
thing as far as faux paws I mean there's
a million oh um one of my students who
was in who's in my advanced that
filmmaking class he tweeted me one
Tuesday are one Friday when we had class
and he tweeted me saying that he wasn't
going to be in class today because today
was his 21st birthday and he's already
so drunk he can't walk so you know it
was funny
but I told them you know you don't want
to do that so try to keep it you know
constructive as much as possible you
know it's interesting hearing you say
that you know Gary Potts key and actor
sort of he's the one that persuaded you
the filmmaker to get on you know Twitter
you know you know cuz you know often you
know me being the filmmaker I'm off
three encouraging actors like hey you
know what you need to get them involved
you know whether it be Facebook Twitter
you know whatever interment in terms of
social media and just start you know
engaging and connecting with people you
know what are your thoughts on that the
fact that you know here you are the
filmmaker being interests you know sort
of guided by an actor and do bc enough
actors building their brands and
engaging with people on twitter facebook
etc well i think it's great I mean Gary
really dragged me into the social media
world you know I mean I had a myspace
page and I had just gotten on facebook
you know maybe 07 I think something like
that but he was he really since he works
in academic technology he's up on all
this stuff and he was he was a very very
early Twitter user and I remember him
talking about it I'm just like well it's
not kind of like text messages you know
yeah I didn't get it um and since the
community's gotten bigger you know we
get it now but he's been from the very
beginning you know he's he was really
you know the leader as far as getting us
to get onto these networks and how to be
successful within them and I think
that's really gonna help him in his
career I mean as actors go he is at the
you know at the forefront of actors that
are social media savvy you know you
think of him you think of wonder Russell
you know these are people who have a
brand as a performer you know and people
know who they are almost as much as
they're almost almost as much because of
their presence on these sites as their
work itself so you know if you're trying
to promote yourself that's really what
you want so I mean these guys they
really know what they're doing and you
know insurance it's going to be
dividends from it for a real long time
who are some other indie filmmakers that
you like to emulate on Twitter that you
like an ed burns or you know Kevin Smith
like who are somebody the sort of the
heavy hitters and indie film that you
like to emulate Ted hope uh well I love
that ho um he he really has like exposed
me to the higher art of indie film
through the stuff that he puts on
Twitter you know I found out about films
that I never otherwise would have you
know by reading his feed by reading his
blog on you know Kevin Smith his film
he's special to me because his films
were the first films that I really
watched and loved and thought wow you
know maybe I could make something like
that you know back when I was in college
and you know and I actually got the
chance to meet him he came to the
University Connecticut to do a speaking
engagement and I start that security in
bed him in the back room and he was
awesome it was great you know I found
out I told them chasing amy was my
favorite movie he said that it was his
do so that was pretty broke uh you know
those those guys are really you know
people that I look up to a lot I like it
burns and I like the idea that he's as
involved with his audience as he isn't
making of his films now through Twitter
I think that's really cool i like the
fact that John Sayles is becoming a
little bit more Twitter friendly I think
that's really you know it he's another
Idol of mine so I think that's something
that's really cool I wish more bigger
filmmakers would get on Twitter and
start sharing you know some stuff about
the way that they do things like if the
Coen brothers were on Twitter I would
follow them and I would just I wouldn't
stalk them for everyone because I think
they're amazing filmmakers and I think
that would be a great way for them to
reach their audience in markham rd are
you surprised that there is still not a
viable distribution outlet or platform
for independent film and do we really
need one um I'm not really surprised
that there's not one now only because
we're at a point now where there's so
much experimentation you know work I
think we're going to find one um I don't
know what that is you know I mean you
look at something like tog as far as
theatrical and being able to you know to
round up crowds to have films cone I
think that maybe something that
becomes popular as time goes on you can
already see they're partnering with
focus features for a phone call
extraterrestrial that's coming on soon
there at the partnering with Todd to do
crowdsource screams so I think we're a
couple years away from really seeing
what the most effective way is but I
think and I think it's something that we
need to have because you know
experimentation is great but ultimately
experimentation more feed you so if we
can find something that works it's going
to be something that a lot of people are
going to gravitate towards obviously I
think we need that I'm not saying that's
the only way that distribution should be
done whatever that one way becomes um
but I think you know it's the idea of
best practice you know whatever whatever
becomes most successful is what people
are going to gravitate towards so I
think you know in the next couple years
we'll find out exactly what that is i'm
indy visitor do you still think that
independent filmmakers are putting too
much emphasis on film festivals on
theatrical screenings and really you
know we need that we need to figure out
a better way a more appropriate way to
share work online oh I i think the
festival model is something that needs
to really be revisited um I a lot of
people are posted on foam courage calm
about such things i have um i think
there is a role for the film festival
for an independent film if they're
looking to build an audience um but I
think it needs to be targeted like what
we're doing with rising star bringing
the films through the Connecticut Film
Festival to all these different
screenings is something that's going to
get us a lot of local press and that
local market is the one that we want to
hit with DVD sales with on-demand
screenings like that kind of stuff with
online viewing I think the the wider a
net you cast the less relevant film
festivals become that's that's my
opinion you know if you if you've got
something that's that's hyperlocal
I think you can use them to your
advantage and and I mean we're a great
example like I I didn't submit the film
to the Connecticut film festival I
called the director and said I want to
work you know I want to bring you in on
this so it's something where you know
the filmmaker is really the one driving
the creation of this event and I think
the more filmmaker can do that the more
a filmmaker can take advantage of the
press attributes that a festival like
that has and in a lot of cases a
filmmaker may not have relationships
with radio outlets TV outlets newspapers
stuff like that so there really is the
really is hope in a use for that you
know if you're if you know who exactly
who it is that you're targeting um I
forgot the second half of your question
sorry you know it was all about like the
you know a viable distribution our maybe
that was a last one but forgive me out
my mind's already moving forward Mario
Mario it's my next question next Marty
answer the next I just want to go back
to the seattle trip ended film festival
you were thinking of that festival um
what are you expecting no like what are
you honestly expecting you know world
premiere in your film you know all way
across the country you know I mean this
is less than two weeks away you know how
have you been preparing for it and what
are you expecting coming out of it well
I think the biggest thing that we did
you know once we found out that we were
getting in was that we wanted to make
sure that we sold out the screening that
was the biggest thing for us and we did
we found out about three days ago that
the screening sold out so that's all
graduations thank you very much um so
now the thing we're trying to do is
we're trying to convince the best of all
to have a screen in a second time so I'm
gets all that out too um but what I
think the biggest thing that we want to
get out of this is just a big splash we
this film to come out and we want people
talking about it out there because
Seattle is a huge indie film town we you
know we all know you know it's the Lynn
Shelton's the Megan Griffiths of the
world you know Stefan are else is up
there Lacey 11 you know all these all
these great filmmakers are making all
these great films you know if if we're
looking to change our focus from making
films on a Connecticut level two films
on a national level
where people all over the country will
know about us these are the backgrounds
in which we need to play because the
people that are going to be there will
be able to talk to these heavier hitters
it's as much a press strategy as it is
anything else um you know I really want
you know but I'm trying to contact the
seattle times right now they have a
movie reviewer and i'm trying like mad
to get her you know it's a comment to
review the film because if that film
review is good that's in like a top 20
national newspaper that to me is as good
as the new york times so if we can do
that and that's part of the reason why i
thought seattle was a good place to go
you know despite the fact they were the
first one to accept us it looked good to
me because it's a huge media market so
if we can make a splash there and if we
can let people you know a lot of people
find out about us there it'll be good
you know and and there's other elements
to its who besides just the film we're
bringing out one of our hip-hop artists
that had seven songs on the soundtrack i
didn't clockwise him and his manager in
clock they're both coming out to seattle
with us and clockwise is going to be
performing in seattle so all these
people in the music scene out there
which is also huge they're going to hear
about this movie when they go to see
this guy perform so you know really it's
it's about getting our name out there
and trying to kind of break out of the
oh well we're good connecticut
filmmakers we want to be we're good
filmmakers so i think this is a good way
to do that no but give us the inside
scoop Marty how is a connecticut-based
filmmaker you know selling out a
screening three you know a film festival
screening 3,000 miles away I mean how
much of that is your network you know
your sort of fan base so you know who
you're dealing with and how much of that
is sort of this Seattle to independent
film festival and their base you know
because I've had films screen all over
the country film festivals all over the
country and and it's not uncommon for
for a film festival to maybe have with
just a handful of people that actually
tend to screen him it's very it's very
challenging how did you do it well I can
speak my my own personal work on over
the last couple years I you know the
that I met on Twitter who are in Seattle
people that have been on facebook who
are in Seattle I've kept track of where
all my filmmaker friends live and you
know I've got as big a list in Austin as
I do in Seattle as i do in orlando and
you know once we found out that that's
where we're going I just contacted all
my friends that were there and I said
look it's not unlike crowdfunding you
know you contact these people and you
say listen we got great news the film
that we made here a year and a half ago
just got into this festival you know is
there any chance you could go to the
screening if you can awesome can you
tell your friends about us it's the same
thing and you know there's a there's a
girl Aria who I've become friends with
on Facebook I followed her short film
spider a couple years ago and we just
you know stayed in contact talkin every
now and again you know not every day and
when I found out that it got in i
contacted her and I said hey great news
i'm coming to town in a month you know
can you let your friends know about us
and she said absolutely she started
contacting all her friends they bought a
couple of tickets so for them you know
it's a night out to go see a cool movie
but for Aria you know it's a chance to
meet a guy that you've been talking with
online for the last couple of years and
you know it was also a filmmaker so it's
a very similar process to crowdfunding
as far as getting tickets sold and
lastly morning what I love about you is
that you're so resourceful you know
you're generous with your time and and
you seem like you're always busy and and
inventive and all these things and it's
great it was great to watch you two like
in action with the students and then in
between like the screening you were
helping someone with their project what
do you do to unwind and relax and and
cuz I'm sure I mean you seem like you're
such a giver how do you how do you have
Marty time cuz you just seem like such a
generous person oh well thank ya um i
wish i had more Marty time uh I mean
pretty much these days like I hang out
at home a lot you know a number i live
with some really great guys so you know
we'll we'll hang out and watch baseball
and have a beer and just chat you know
it's cool guys that live with have
nothing to do with the movie industry so
you know I have as much of a chance of
talking about
you know facing cars as I do you know
talking about the Oscars so that's
that's always cool like singing karaoke
not much of a singer but I like doing it
Oh what are your best hit what's your
best karaoke Oh God um don't stop
believin no not fulfilling anything
hip-hop is usually where I where I do
the best work so yeah all right we've
been speaking with Marnie lang writer
director and producer of rising star for
more on Marnie and rising star please
visit rising star movie com on twitter
at rising star movie and mari underscore
lang don't forget the underscore um and
also facebook.com slash rising star
movie yeah yeah thank you again Marty
you know it's great you know I'm envious
that you've been able to shoot and
finish a feature in Connecticut um it's
been great to connect with you here on
film courage and we're just we're super
excited for the upcoming world premiere
to think that you've already sold it out
already um this is extraordinary so just
congratulations we ran we just wish you
nothing but success yeah it was great to
hang out with you this weekend so yeah
same here guys yeah alright thanks Marty